So, you're in a heated argument, and out
of nowhere, you feel it. Tears starting
to well up in your eyes, and no matter
how much you're fighting it, there's
just no stopping them from coming. What
do you do when you cry in an argument?
Well, I'll tell you.
Absolutely
nothing. Don't you dare
for 1 second be ashamed or embarrassed
that you cry.
Do you feel embarrassed or ashamed when
your shoulders get tense, or your jaw
gets tight, or your eyebrows go down
because your body's not liking the
situation? Your body's reacting
naturally to what's happening. Do you
apologize then?
Of course you don't. It's the same thing
for when you cry. It is just biology.
It's what happens. It is your stress in
liquid form. So, the next time you feel
tears starting to well up in your eyes,
this is what I want you to do. Here's
some three rules I'm going to give you
right now.
Number one, don't ever apologize for it.
Don't say, "I'm I'm so sorry. I'm
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I'm crying
right now. Geez, I'm so sorry. I'm so
embarrassed." Absolutely not.
I will not allow that. I won't allow
that word.
You There's nothing to be ashamed of.
There's nothing you should be
apologizing for. It's how your body is
responding. Unless you're crying about a
topic that
you know, it's it's maybe it's funny.
Maybe it's something that it's not
appropriate to cry at, but
I can't even envision that. Don't
apologize for what your body is
naturally responding to in that moment.
Number two, don't even acknowledge them.
That means when you're in an argument
with someone, and you're having a a
difficult conversation, and it's a
difficult moment, and you start to cry,
don't even acknowledge them. Just wipe
them away, and keep on talking.
Wipe them away, and keep on talking. If
you can grab a tissue, great. If not,
just wipe them away
and keep on talking. Don't acknowledge
that because if anything, it serves as a
distraction. It calls attention to it.
Number three, if you need to label the
tears.
What I mean by that is if you feel
yourself crying, you can say, "These are
tired tears.
These are stressed tears. These are
tears that care. These are tears that um
are are
understanding the importance of this
moment." You find different words to
label the tears that doesn't feel like
you're just crying to cry. No, it's your
body responding to what is natural in
that moment. And let's talk for a second
about what crying is. When you cry, it
activates your parasympathetic nervous
system. It is the opposite of your fight
or flight mode. This is your rest,
digest, relaxation mode. What that means
is when you start to cry, your body is
helping you. It is trying to release
emotions. It is trying to soothe you.
Because in that moment, in that
argument, in that fight, your body's
telling you something. Your body's
saying, "Hey, your stress cup, it's too
full.
It's too full. It's about to overflow.
Let me take care of that for you." And
it does that in a way that you can start
to release emotions in the form of
liquid.
That's it.
So, the higher the tension,
the higher the release. That's why it
makes sense when you cry to say, "I'm
These are just calm tears. My body's
calming down." No, this is This is These
are tears that that care. I'm listening.
Keep talking.
See what I mean? And when you just say
say to the other person, "Keep talking."
Even when you're crying, "Keep talking.
I'm listening." In other words, don't
worry about this. This is just my body
taking care of myself. See what I'm
doing right now? This is normal. This is
uh natural.
Let's Let's get rid of the stigma that
just because you're crying, it means
that you're trying to get attention.
Just because you're crying, it means
that you can't take the present moment.
No, it's your body fully prepared and
equipped to handle the conflict in front
of you. There's nothing wrong with it.
So, understand that when the tears come,
it is your body calming you down. It is
your body acting and processing exactly
the way it was made. And if you followed
my content for any amount of time,
you're going to recognize this phrase.
When you claim it,
you control it.
And I say it because it's applicable in
many different contexts, especially when
it comes to crying.
When you claim it, you control it. What
it means is when you say things out
loud, when you say how you're feeling
out loud,
you're able to control that emotion
better by acknowledging it out in the
open. So, instead of saying, "I'm sad."
and becoming the emotion, it's I can
tell I'm feeling sad. And now you
separated and distanced yourself from
that feeling. And now you can process
it. Now you can deal with it. Now you
can communicate about it rather than
bottling it up all inside of you. And
that's why labeling is so important.
When you can say to the other person, "I
can tell that I'm frustrated." or "I can
tell these are These are tired tears.
Keep talking. I'm listening." then it's
no problem because it looks like you're
emotionally intelligent. It looks like
you're the person who's more in control
than rather, "What's going on with you?
What's happening?" Oh, "I don't want to
talk about it." and you're just bottling
it up all inside. So, when you can claim
it, you control it and it makes you so
much more confident in that moment that
you're not worried about crying. You're
not worried about tears. Instead, you're
focused on communicating in the moment
in that present conversation. And I also
want to touch on what do you do when
someone else is crying in front of you
in an argument. So you're in a
conversation one-on-one, what do you do
when the other person begins to cry?
Well, here's what you don't do. You
don't do, "Oh, okay, this again?"
You don't do that. You don't say, "Oh,
okay, fine. Got it. All right, yes, you
got to cry. Fine." And act like it is
some inconvenience to you.
That's a problem.
That's that's
that is toxic behavior
to act that way. That is immature,
emotionally immature, to say, "Oh, this
again? Okay. All right, I guess we'll
just take a time out." No.
We're not going to do that. If somebody
is crying in an argument, you don't
address it. Same thing for rule number
two for when you're the one crying.
You don't address it. You just continue
to keep talking with them. That means
you don't break eye contact. That means
you don't say, "Oh, do you mean need a
minute? You need a minute?"
Uh it's it's fine. No, you you don't
break any of that communication. You
still look at them like a normal person
and understand they're just talking. You
wouldn't do that, "So you need a break?"
If you see their shoulders get tense.
So you're just going to say nothing and
continue to talk. Don't acknowledge it.
If you need anything at all, if you were
to do anything, it might be to if a
tissue's nearby, grab it and just hand
it to them and keep on talking or keep
on listening.
But don't at all make them feel ashamed.
Don't at all try to make them feel like
they're an inconvenience to the
conversation
because they can't help it in many ways.
Now, I will say that there are some
because I I I understand this that this
is very true. Some people will use tears
as manipulation.
I mean, we get it from kids. My my
4-year-old, she I have a 6-year-old son
and 4-year-old daughter. And
don't get me wrong, they both can turn
on the waterworks
like a faucet at any time, and they can
quickly turn it off.
But that's all the more reason why you
can't acknowledge it in that moment.
Now, if it's indication that they're
upset, it's different with kids. Let's
put this in terms of mature adults,
hopefully we're mature adults.
When they feel like they're crying,
if you feel that all that they're
manipulating the situation,
well, then that's all the more reason
for you not to acknowledge it. It's not
you being dismissive, it's you staying
in the lane of the conversation, saying,
"No, I'm I'm focused on the words. I'm
not focused on how your body is reacting
in this moment, whether it's genuine,
whether it's sincere or not. I'm focused
on the words and how we're going to
communicate this message back and
forth." Okay, now it's the part of the
podcast where I get to read an email
from a follower and answer their
question. If you don't already know, I
have a newsletter where I send out one
communication tip once a week right to
your inbox totally for free, and those
who respond, I'm able to communicate
with, and I get lots of ask me
uh questions, AMAs that I try to respond
here. So, I have the uh it'll be in the
show notes that you can sign up for
yourself if you'd like, and I have one
right here on my other phone.
So, this one comes from Sandy. She is
over in Georgia, in Georgia, United
States,
and uh Sandy says, "Hey Jefferson, thank
you so much. I always watch your
content." Thank Thank you, Sandy.
"I find myself in the position of always
feeling like I'm a mess
in difficult conversations."
I'm sorry, Sandy.
"I feel like I start to
uh shake, my voice gets to gets shaky,
and I begin to cry a whole lot. Do you
have any tips for me?"
Understand when I read these, it's I'm
trying to skip over personal details
that they Sandy probably wouldn't want
me to share. So, Sandy, I'm sorry about
that. I I don't want you to feel as if
you're having to always be a mess, that
you're trying to put yourself back
together again. That's one thing I want
to highlight would be my my first
recommendation to you is don't say out
loud, "I'm just a mess. I need to Give
me a second. I need to put myself
together."
That's not the case.
Your crying is your body putting
yourself together.
Your crying is your body
soothing yourself. So, let's address
two different issues. One, you said you
you shake a lot. You get nervous. When
you get nervous, uh your voice is
shaking in the conversation. That's very
natural. That's very normal. That is the
um the fight and flight mode, all right?
That's the adrenaline going through your
body and getting you all hyped, and that
often results in your muscles starting
to shake because your muscles are
reacting and ready to either fight or
run from any given situation. The way
you control that is your breath, Sandy.
Is in
>> [sighs]
>> and out. You see how you can just relax
those shoulders, just like that? So,
whenever you're in a situation where
your voice is really shaky, like that,
go back to your breath.
Every time.
Speak on the out breath. Often, when
you're shaking, it's because you're
holding your breath because you feel
nervous in that situation and tenses
everything up. That's why sometimes we
yell,
right? We yell because our body is we
bottled it up, put a screw cap on it,
and all of a sudden, when it's ready to
explode, we raise our voice. Just keep
your breath calm and steady and as
rhythmic as you can. By that, I mean,
try to keep it in a
4 seconds in, hold it 4 seconds, release
it 4 seconds, hold it 4 seconds. That's
box breathing. That's what they call
that.
Now, to the other point of you feel like
you're maybe just a bubbling mess. I
want to go back to what I said a minute
ago.
Don't be apologizing for crying and
don't be feeling like you're some mess
that you have to pick up off the floor
and you're going to be an inconvenience
for anybody there.
Instead, just label the tears to the
best that you can. I can tell that these
are overwhelmed tears.
I can tell these are these are happy
tears.
Keep talking.
That's another point that I don't know
if I've hit home enough. It's okay to
tell them, keep talking.
Even when you start to cry or you start
to tear up, rather than acknowledging
them and stopping the conversation, you
can tell them if they start to slow down
a little bit and be like, "Oh, do you
need some time?" Wave it off. Then you
can keep talking. Keep talking. I'm
listening.
In other words, you're saying, "I'm not
worried about what's happening. You
don't need to be worried about what's
happening. Let's just keep talking in
this conversation because my body's
doing exactly what it's it's made to
do." So, keep your breath calm.
And when you feel those tears come,
don't apologize for them. Don't feel
embarrassed about them. Instead, just
label them to whatever is honest and
sincere and genuine in that moment. All
right, the next time you cry in an
argument, what are we going to do?
Number one, we're not going to
apologize. We're not going to say, "I'm
so sorry." We're not going to make it
feel like an inconvenience. We are
absolutely not going to apologize.
Listen to me.
Don't apologize for it. There's nothing
to be ashamed of. Number two, we're not
going to acknowledge them.
We're not going to stop the conversation
and we're not going to allow the other
person to stop the conversation.
Instead, we're going to say something
like, "I'm listening. You can keep
going."
Don't acknowledge them as if this is
something that is totally normal, as
something that neither one of you should
be afraid of. Number three, if you need
to, label the tears. Meaning, say the
feeling that is triggering the fear.
These are tired tears. These are tears
that care. ways that you can communicate
because when you claim it, you control
it. Here's the truth. You can't control
another person's emotions, but you can
control how much power their emotions
have over you. Today, I'm going to teach
you how to stay in control even when the
conversation turns emotional. All that
and more coming right up.
Now, I will be the first to admit
I have trouble sometimes in conversation
when the other person gets emotional.
That's That's me being honest and
transparent with you.
If somebody is getting really emotional,
whether it's anger, meaning they
escalate in anger, or maybe they're
really sad and they're crying a whole
lot, or maybe they feel really closed
off, or they're having big emotions,
that's hard for me to process sometimes.
Throughout this episode, I want you to
see the conversation between me and you,
or you and another person,
as you two in a circle, in a enclosed,
confined space, but let's give it some
room, let's not be claustrophobic. Give
yourselves some some space.
That it's this preserved bubble that
you're in, that is a circle, and whether
or not how much space you have in this
conversation for emotion. Like I said,
sometimes I have a hard time with that.
I tend to be um somebody who can
sometimes see emotions as a distraction
to the point or the goal or the finish
line of what I'm wanting to communicate,
and sometimes that's good. As an
attorney, that's how we're taught. All
right? I can have clients that are very
emotional right in front of me, and it
won't affect me at all. And there's
sometimes that, yeah, I get pulled on my
heartstrings, and I I want to help, and
I'm there, and there are other times
where it is it's just part of the
process because I've seen a lot of
emotion. People come to me, and a lot of
trial attorneys can relate to this. I
They're seeing I'm seeing them at some
of the lowest, hardest points of their
life. And so, it's also a sign of
strength for me to say, I can take on
your emotion.
I can be here with you.
I and at the same time, I can still be
empathetic without trying to make you
feel worse or make it feel like you
shouldn't feel this way. So, there's
some part of it
where emotion's just part of the game. I
can or I'm I might be deposing a witness
asking questions and they start to cry.
That's That's part of it. So, sometimes
I have to see through that emotion.
That's professionally. In relationship
side, that's just part of the the life.
That's part of the relationship is to be
vulnerable with those emotions of how
you're feeling. And I I'm definitely not
going to talk to a witness when they're
going through some time of emotion that
I'm going to talk with my wife or my mom
or my dad or my siblings or my kids. So,
it's
it's understanding context, it's
understanding environment. So, let's
call that the the bubble in this. So,
admittedly, sometimes I have trouble
with that. That's just me being honest.
And there are other times where despite
me having difficulty sometime, I can
tell you how to control
your own self in the conversation even
when they get emotional. And I don't do
this I'm not telling you this in some
kind of hidden trick way or there's some
kind of Jedi mind trick. There's not.
There's just very simple key things I
want you to keep in mind when somebody
else
on the other side is trying to get
emotional. So, I want you to kind of nod
your head right now if that's you. You
feel like when other people get
emotional in the conversation, you don't
know how to process that.
Maybe you get you tense up, maybe you
freeze, maybe you want to distance
yourself from it. You're not really sure
how to do it and you're you feel awkward
all of a sudden. I want to reassure you
that's totally normal. All right? I can
I can relate to that to some extent. So,
I want to help you through this in this
episode. So here we go. You ready?
Number one, what I want you to do when
it comes to maintaining control when the
other person gets emotional is to
understand first before you start even
assessing the other person.
Understand your own physical cues.
And I mean physical. So understand how
in that moment their emotions affect
your physical.
Meaning do you find that your face
scrunches up?
Like I'm doing right now.
Do you find that your body or your neck
tenses up? Regardless of the emotion
that they're showing. Let's Let's not go
into the details yet. Let's Let's keep
it surface and then we'll go deep.
What happens when you perceive any kind
of emotion?
Cuz most of the time whether it's happy
or sad, we still have a physical
reaction to it from whatever emotion
that they're showing.
So maybe you scoot away. Maybe your head
looks away cuz you don't want to
face it. Maybe you feel like you
Maybe you
clench your fists. I was thinking of the
word. I didn't know the forgot the word.
You clench your fists in some extent. We
all have a physical reaction and your
job right now is to think of yours. Just
5 seconds.
What tends to be your first gut reaction
when somebody on the other side of you
gets emotional? For me,
I find that often
it's difficult for me to keep eye
contact with them because I don't want
them feel that they're
on the witness stand or they are on this
pedestal or they are
all eyes are on them and sometimes eye
contact makes it harder on the other
person.
So maybe I might avoid my eyes.
Sometimes I can shut down. In other
words, I'm going to distance myself a
little bit because I don't want to be
maybe too strong in the conversation.
Um so that tends to be sometimes that
that happens to somebody gets really
really emotional in the conversation.
And it also depends, which I'm here you
saying right now is Jefferson, it
depends what kind of emotion they're
showing.
And I I understand that. If it's sadness
and the other person is very sad and
let's say they're crying a whole lot,
you know, I don't know really how to
deal with that. What I can tell you is
that it's not helpful if you try to
avoid it and distance. Why? Because it
makes them feel all the more isolated.
Instead, you have to get comfortable
with understanding your physical cues
and being comfortable around what
they're doing in that sadness. That
shows empathy. That shows sympathy.
That shows that their emotions aren't
scaring you off.
If it's anger that they're showing,
different story because what happens, we
typically hold our breath
and then we start to prepare to run, to
yell, to fight back. We're It's the
fight or flight fully on board. We don't
know if we want to throw hurtful words,
escalate the behavior. So what is the
main key that drives this?
Is your physical cues.
Your body will almost always betray you
in that way.
They've ever heard when somebody goes,
"What's You seem like you're mad." And
you're like, "I don't know.
I'm not mad." And like, "Okay, well,
your your face and your voice say you
do."
It's because your body knows.
Regardless of what you say in your mind,
your body knows.
And sometimes it will betray you that
way.
In ways that you're not expecting. So,
number one, understand your physical
cues. If you don't know naturally what
you do when you're feeling the emotions
of somebody else,
ask a friend.
Ask your closest friend, a partner, a
spouse, a parent. Say, "Hey, when things
get emotional, what do you see that I I
tend to do?" Ask them that question and
I promise you'll learn something.
It's It's going to help you. Why Why do
you want to know your physical cues?
Because that is step one. If you cannot
control your physical cues, if you do
not know what's happening to your body
in that moment, then I cannot help you.
Then nobody can help you. Then you will
not have control when the person gets
emotional. If you cannot at least
acknowledge and identify what your
physical cues are. Cool? Okay, number
two. I want you to start using phrases
in your head that ground you.
That sounds woo-woo. It's not. I promise
it's not. I do it. And I don't I'm not a
woo-woo fan. So,
what does that mean? Use phrases in your
head to ground yourself.
We're going to talk to ourself and use
phrases when the other person's getting
emotional that help us stay in the
moment. When I say present, I mean my
mind is not off somewhere else. I am
here. I'm focused in on what is
happening in front of me. I'm not in the
past. I'm not in the future. I am right
here in this moment. There is no other
point in time that will ever be the same
as when I am listening to you right now.
And I might need to use phrases that I'm
going to say to myself that you and I
are going to work out together that's
that are going to be personal to you
that are going to help you
make sure and realize that your feet are
planted. So, wherever you are right now,
if you're listening, maybe you're
standing, maybe you're walking, maybe
you're in your car, I want you just like
wiggle your toes. Remember the those
guys?
Yeah, you maybe you forgot that they
were there. Wiggle them for a second.
Okay, cool. Now, just keep them still.
That's I I want to just put this image
of grounding. So, just push your feet,
if you can, into the ground. The soles
of your feet, of your shoes, your socks,
feel it in the ground. That is you
planted in that moment. So, what we're
going to do, we're going to use phrases
that help you. And I'm going to share
with you two of mine. All right? Number
one, when somebody's getting emotional,
what I say to myself is the same thing
that I say if I find that I'm getting
defensive. Because often, if there's
anger in front of me, that emotion, I
want to pick it up.
So, what do I ground myself with? I use
the phrase, "Put it down, Jefferson."
I I'm not kidding. I immediately will
go, "Put it down, Jefferson. Put it
down."
"Put it down." I think of my my son
picking something off the ground and I'm
like, "Uh let let go of that. You don't
need to be picking up this
uh I don't know. It could be whatever
kids pick up that is best that they
not." So, you name it.
Or I just go in my head, "Put it down,
Jefferson. That's not yours to carry.
That's not yours to pick up. It is not
yours. It is their emotion.
Don't pick it up. You can see it. You
can acknowledge it.
I say, "Put it down, Jefferson."
So, right now, just say it to yourself.
Whatever your name is,
"Put it down."
See how that feels to you. You're going
to come up maybe with your own personal
phrase that feels good to you to remind
you to drop it.
Drop it. Don't take on their emotion.
You are here in the present, grounded,
without trying to add anything else to
it. Another that I like Another that I
like
is I will say to myself, "There is space
for this."
"There is space for this."
Meaning if I'm in a conversation with
somebody who's starting to get
emotional, whether it's sadness or
anger,
I ground myself with the phrase, "There
is space for this." Meaning two things
can be true at the same time.
I can have my emotions and they can have
their emotions and two things can be
true at the same time.
Both emotions can be true. Doesn't mean
either one is right. Doesn't mean either
one is less valid than the other. Two
things can be true at the same time.
There is space for both of this.
So, maybe I'm mad, right? And maybe my
wife is really sad.
Or vice versa.
It doesn't It doesn't mean that either
one of us
is on a bad playing field. It It means
that there is space for both of this. Or
maybe I am having a conversation with
um an attorney
who's really grinding my gears.
And this attorney's getting heated.
Well, I know that's coming from a
purpose and a reason. I'm not going to
let that control me. For me to control
myself and control the conversation,
even when they start to get emotional,
is to remind myself there's space for
this.
There's enough room.
So, that goes back to the circle that we
talked about, this bubble.
So, if there's space for it, we're going
to widen that enough. The circle between
me and you right now, there's enough
space. If there's not, then we have to
widen our circle. That means I If
there's not enough space, it means that
bubble doesn't include both of us. It
only includes me.
And if that's the case, then that's the
conversation you
we're going to have to rethink from the
very beginning, because that's a
conversation you don't really want to be
in, and that's a conversation that the
other person doesn't deserve you in.
So, because that's that's that's not a
two-way connection. You feel me? So,
when you are both in the bubble,
the circle of communicating,
it's okay for you to ground yourself
to make sure you have control
to say, "There is space for this."
That's Those are two of my favorites.
Now, you can make any
phrase that you want. It's totally up to
you.
Totally up to you. A phrase that's going
to ground you.
There is no right answer. There is no
wrong answer.
It is simply a reminder of, "I am here.
This emotion is valid. Or this emotion I
see. This um This emotion I observe."
Rather than taking it and knitting it
into a sweater and then putting it on,
deciding that that's now your emotion,
too. And you're going to get worked up
about it. All right? That's how to
continue to maintain control even when
they get emotional. Number three, what I
want you to stand in line with here is
that
even when they get emotional, there's a
boundary.
There is a boundary.
That is a boundary that protects you.
In other words, they don't really have
to do anything. So, that means if
they're starting to raise their voice,
and this really goes for things that are
negative. In other words, it's anger,
it's rage, it's frustration, irritation
that they're trying to put on you.
They're They're trying to color you in
those emotions.
When that kind of thing happens, you put
up a boundary with that.
What I mean is, first off, we're not
going to mirror what you see. If they
start to get angry, we're not going to
mirror that. If they start to raise
their voice,
and and their level is at a level six,
that doesn't mean you're going to see it
as a competition and raise it to level
eight. That's not maintaining control.
That is simply giving away your control.
That means the louder they get, the more
steady your voice will be. That means
the faster they go, the slower your
voice is going to sound. And I promise
you, you will always sound more in
control of that conversation than the
other person. What happens is they're
going to eventually regulate to come
back down. So, how do you maintain that
that boundary? Here's some phrases that
I like. One is I I set up this framework
that
I do not X
Y Z.
If you continue to X Y and Z, then this
is the end of the conversation for me.
For example,
I don't respond to somebody who's
yelling at me.
If you continue to yell and raise your
voice,
this is the end of the conversation.
Simple as that. Simple boundary.
Now, it's it's If they want to continue
to talk, now they know the rules of the
game, the rules of play.
I don't respond to disrespect. If you
continue to talk with me in that tone,
this is the end of the conversation for
me.
That's still a boundary.
Every bit of a boundary.
You can still be there for their
emotions. You still can be there to
observe them,
but also maintain your own sense of
self-worth and self-respect, making sure
that that doesn't get diluted or watered
down.
Another that I really like is, I'm
willing to talk, not be talked over.
Or I'm willing to talk,
and I'm not willing to talk like this.
That's one of my favorites.
Because I'm I'm what I'm doing is I'm
using and not but.
This is how my my weird brain goes. So,
if I say,
I'm willing to talk,
but not like this,
that but deletes I'm willing to talk.
I think it's stronger my
professional opinion of I'm willing to
talk,
and I'm not willing to talk like this.
So, it it's very clear
of what I'm willing to do and what I'm
not willing to do.
You can shorten it however you like. I'm
not trying to be super nitpicky. It's
It's going to be whatever is right for
you. Maybe you want to say, I'm not
comfortable continuing to talk like
this.
If we continue to talk this way,
I I'm going to need a break.
I'm going to need a time out. Those are
boundaries to protect you. So, even when
they start to get overly emotional, that
is you maintaining control in the
conversation. They're short, they're
simple, they are there to help you,
and if the other person abides by them,
they're also there to help the other
person as well. No matter what motion
tends to bubble up on the surface.
So,
when somebody's getting emotional in the
conversation and you're not really sure
what to do, what did we talk about?
Number one, you're going to maintain and
understand and identify your own
physical cues. What is happening to you
and your body? Your body will drive the
train. Number two, you're going to find
yourself grounding in that moment,
staying planted and present by using
phrases that help remind you to do that.
Like there is space for this. Two things
can be true at the same time. I can be
mad and they can be sad and that's okay.
Three,
don't let yourself be walked over. If
you need to hold a boundary, do not let
their emotions all of a sudden become
your emotions. Don't let them just take
a stamp and stamp you with them and say,
"You have to also be upset if I'm
upset." I've seen that too sometimes in
people who
in relationships, they feel like, "I
just want you to argue with me. I want
you to be mad like I'm mad." They want
you to show some kind of emotion to see
if it's the feel something.
Be very careful with that because often
that's just a manipulation technique.
That's a technique that they want to
self-soothe in some way
because they are dependent on your match
of emotion that may or may not be
healthy for you. I'm not saying that you
have to be somebody who's closed off
and you totally
shut them out. That's not what I'm
saying whatsoever. At the same time, I'm
not saying that you have to be someone
of just because of they're mad, well now
you have to be mad. That's also just as
unhealthy. So, watch out for that. You
are not a target.
You are not somebody's punching bag. You
are not somebody's outlet for all of
their frustration and their anger and
their insecurities that have been built
up all their life.
This episode is a little bit different
for the podcast. One, it's very early on
a Saturday morning and I wanted to
record this so that I had the full day
with the kids. So, if it looks like my
face hasn't woken up yet, it's because
it hasn't. It's we're in the middle of
the book tour, which is going fantastic,
but I wanted to make time to tell you
what is on my heart. You ready?
So, my book has been out for a little
over a week now, and it's been
fantastic, amazing. The book tour is
going wonderful. And as any new debut
author, I, for good or for bad, have
been looking at reviews online. Cuz you
want to know are people going to like
the book? That's the whole You get very
nervous. Are
Are you going to deliver on the message?
And the reviews have been so kind and
wonderful. And there was one that hit me
yesterday that I randomly saw that I
wanted to share with you. It's very
short. I know you can listen to it. Just
bear with me. I know you can do it.
Listen.
You are not a target.
I was once told by my husband, "You are
an easy target, and everyone knows it."
Time and again, I walked away defeated,
even with my children. Jefferson showed
me what I lacked was communication
skills. From his social media, I started
applying these answers to difficult
situations.
Let me be clear. This is not a book of
his social media clips. That's what I
thought it would be. No. It is learning
to understand where people are and to
adequately communicate with them. It's
teaching to deepen relationships by way
of strong communication skills. You are
not a weak person for purchasing this
book.
You are strong and courageous for
recognizing there is a better way to
bridge a gap, create healthy boundaries
that work, to not get sucked down a
rabbit hole, to not think you've lost
your mind.
I highly recommend, and I'm starting my
second read-through. Kindle edition is
an easy read. Bless you, Jefferson, for
exhibiting love for people.
I was just taken aback by I was totally
blown away by this.
I've no clue who this person is. In
fact, they even leave their name. It
just says verified purchaser.
This is my point with this is I want you
to know where to go
in your mind
when conflict comes your way. You are
not a target.
And if you felt like you've been your
whole life, this is where it stops.
Rule number one in my book, there are
three rules. It's Rule number one, say
it with control. Number two, say it with
confidence. Number three, say it to
connect.
And the whole focus of Rule number one
is you can't say anything about what I
teach you, whether it's my phrases, my
quips, my little words, everything that
I I I can give you. None of it matters
if you do not say it
with control. If you do not first
regulate yourself.
So, we're going to talk about in this
episode what I want you to think about
when conflict comes your way.
Anytime that somebody says something
that you weren't expecting,
your body, naturally through its
biology, reacts.
People think that fight or flight is
something that has to happen when you
come with physical contact. No, that's
not true.
It happens every day in these little
micro moments. Even when somebody just
flatly disagrees with you. When somebody
disagrees with your opinion or they say
something you don't like or they call
you an ugly name, your body goes, "Hey
brain, I I didn't like that." And the
brain goes, "Give me a second. Yeah, no,
we definitely didn't like that." And it
naturally reacts. You have a scowl on
your face. You want to say something
back. You get heated. Your neck and jaw
get tense. All biological. All normal.
All natural. So, what do you do with
that?
Rule number one in my book is you use
your breath
>> [sighs]
>> as the first word that you say. And the
reason why is because it adds a distance
between what they say
and how you respond, which gives you
time to regulate yourself, to think of
the quips that I give you and the
sentences I give you. And it also mutual
The other benefit is it allows the other
person to calm down theirs as well.
Gives time for that analytical side to
take over.
Every day, there are little things that
tell your body, "I am threatened."
Somebody cuts in front of you in
traffic. Somebody merges. Somebody's
riding on your bumper. Your body goes,
"I am threatened." That's where road
rage comes from. "I feel threatened in
this environment." When you're talking
with your kids, when somebody um says
something to you that they disagree with
your opinion, they dismiss your idea.
You don't like that. Your body's saying,
"Hey, that feels threatening to me. I
want you to do something for me right
now." Now, if you're driving, don't
worry about it. If you're walking on the
treadmill, don't worry about it. You can
do it later. Do it in your head with me
right now. I want you to think of
behavior that somebody does that really
really upsets you. And we're going to
put a label on it. For example, maybe
it's disrespect,
dismissive,
condescending,
belittling,
rude. Whatever it is, make it yours.
What is a behavior that somebody
exhibits that really just just feels
like it sets you off, that just you just
explode when somebody does this to you.
You got it? You find that word.
Now,
write it down.
And right next to it, I want you to
write "does not threaten me."
"Does not threaten me."
So, the sentence would be
"Dismissiveness does not threaten me."
"Rude comments, back talk,
insults do not threaten me."
This is the mindset I want you to have
when this kind of stuff comes up in your
life. Why? Because it is telling your
body of hey, when somebody raises their
voice, that doesn't threaten me.
When somebody calls me that, the way I'm
reacting and telling my body is
hey, this does not threaten me.
That's what you're doing with your
breath in that moment. That's why we
give it time to tell your body what is
happening in front of me is not a
threat.
Right? It's this idea that
um you have you've seen the big animals
whether it's a lion or an elephant or
something they have like some
maybe a little dog or something it they
just go what is this? It's like a little
animal coming up to a big animal.
They're not threatened in any way.
That's the whole mindset here of hey,
what you're doing is this isn't
threatening to me. I'm seeing right
through it. Cool?
I'm going to tell you a quick story
right now that
um I haven't I don't think I've ever
shared.
This was I don't know maybe 3 weeks ago
or so.
And
where was I? I might have I think I was
in San Diego airport. I was in the San
Diego airport and maybe in San Diego
everything's
blurring blending together at this
moment and it's early. Give me a break.
Is
I got through security at TSA
and went and I was looking for my gate
looking for my gate and I kept following
all the signs and then all of a sudden I
was outside of it outside of the the
security the gate the terminal it wasn't
the terminal. The gate was actually in a
separate terminal and I just walked
myself all the way through. I had
already gone through security. I had
already gone through all the the check
and the getting your stuff out and ready
and giving your ID.
I had I started walking out and I passed
this exit where it goes you know the
point of no return
or has a red line there at the airport.
And I walk out of it
and all of a sudden this is me by myself
and I look and I go
I say this out loud I go, "Oh my gosh, I
got to do this all over again."
Because I have to know I'm going further
down
where separate terminal is.
And I said, "Oh my gosh, I I got to do
this all over again." And a voice that
I had no clue where it was coming from.
Female voice goes
"That's why you should read the sign,
sir."
And I'm trying to find who
that is and I turn and look
and as I'm looking she goes, "You have
no one to blame but yourself, sir.
That's why we have signs."
I don't know if you're feeling this just
hearing it to me.
Just the way
the tone came across
was so condescending
and unexpected and unnecessary.
You ever had that?
"That's why we have signs, sir. You have
no one to blame but yourself."
And I remember
being just taken aback. Oh, who who are
you?
And it was a TSA agent. Now if you're a
TSA agent, I know not everybody is
rough and can be terrible and I hey, I'm
an attorney for crying out loud. Not all
attorneys are bad. There are some TSA
agents that are wonderful. There are
some people that are bad. We all have
bad apples in every profession. This one
right here
this lady, she was middle-aged lady
uh just looked so smug when as soon as
she said that.
And this is what my my body wanted
to come back with some really good
zingers in that moment. I wanted to say
a few things to her
because it was really rude. It was kind
of it was unnecessary.
And
this is what I did.
Of course, I have to practice what I
preach, right?
I gave it
I looked at her for like 5 seconds
trying to figure out
is this
Did she say that?
And I just give it time.
And now she's sitting back and blinking
and looking at me. Her smile is gone.
And this is what I asked her. I said how
do you feel
when you say that kind of thing to
someone?
Does it give you joy?
That's what I said.
Like verbatim.
And immediately
she got red. Like um uh and just got red
in the face
and apologized right there.
I didn't have to prompt anything. She
goes, "I I'm I'm sorry I'm sorry, sir.
You're You're right. I That wasn't kind.
You're You're right, sir. I'm I'm sorry.
Yes, you you you can find the terminal
if you go straight down." And now she's
in helping mode. Now she's in helping
mode. You can go right here and this is
where it's going to be. I would say,
"Oh, well, thank you very much. I
appreciate that. All right. You have a
wonderful day."
You are not a target.
You are not somebody's punching bag. You
are not the outlet for somebody to
release all of their frustrations and
their angers and their smugness
on you.
These tools work. This is why I talk
about at them. That's why I feel so
passionate about sharing these.
You had the choice right in that moment
when somebody says something ugly, when
they're the TSA agent in your life.
How are you going to react? What are you
going to say to that person?
Are you going to allow them to just
pressure remote control and manipulate
all your emotions? I had a choice. You
have a choice.
Is that going to ruin your day? I just
can't believe you'd say that. Excuse me,
is that what Excuse me, are you talking
to me?
I I
You see how it easy it could go the
other way when you give in to that fight
or flight, when you don't use your
breath, when you don't regulate
yourself.
If you do not say things with control,
it doesn't matter
what kind of tip I can give you. It's
not going to work. It ain't going to
work.
You have to say it with control.
You are not
a target.
I hope that
this is a good reminder for you,
wherever you are.
I can give you lots of tools and tips on
what to say.
And we have different podcast episodes
on that, and I'm going to continue to
give you podcast episodes on this.
And I want to make sure that you know,
and you hear, and really the message is
very simple for today.
You are not a target.
When that happens, I want you to go to
your breath,
regulate yourself,
and then use the questions that I've
taught you. These are questions like,
"Did you mean Did you mean for that to
be rude?
Did you mean to insult me? Did you mean
for that to embarrass me?"
Or you give it time, and then you ask
somebody a question of intent. "How did
you expect me to react to that?" I could
have said that to her.
"How did you want me to respond to
that?"
"How does it make you feel?"
Imagine being the person
who would say that to someone.
These These ways of responding to rude
that is actually not a response. It's a
question.
You're not giving them matters of
substance. I'm not saying, "Let me You
You spit in my eye. Let me spit back in
yours."
No. It is a reflection of their own
behavior and character.
And nine times out of 10, the other
person sees that because they because
you're giving them time to are seeing
It's like a the
the blood the the red
Uh it's not blood. The red comes out of
their
system. You know, or somebody's seeing
red, you have to give them time for that
to
go away.
Come back to normal. Come back. I know
that's not who you are. People are not
People are
far better
than we give them a chance to be. Why?
Because we know that in ourselves. So,
when you have the patience and the
discipline to get to that, you're going
to have a better communication and a
better relationship and a better life
because of that.
Cool?
All right. You are not a target. Have a
wonderful day.
>> We all have moments where our emotions
get the best of us, whether it's a hard
conversation at work or a hard
conversation at home. [clears throat] If
you want to have more effective
communication, you have to increase your
emotional intelligence. Emotional
intelligence isn't just a buzzword. It
is something that can transform the way
you communicate, how you understand the
other person, and more importantly, how
you understand yourself. Emotional
intelligence, I like to think of it as
emotional fluency. In other words, I'm
fluent in the language of my emotions. I
can recognize my emotions. I can speak
my emotions, and I can better identify
those emotions in other people. And by
increasing your emotional intelligence,
you take more control over how you feel
and how you can guide the interaction in
the conversation. And I'm going to tell
you how to do that in three easy steps.
Number one, use the phrase I need. It's
as simple as that. Begin your response
with I need. It's a very entry-level way
of being emotionally intelligent. Number
two, have something to learn, not
something to prove. Too often, we're
fighting over who has the right answer,
rather than fighting to ask the right
question. And number three, what
triggers you
teaches you. So, instead of focusing on
what the other person is doing and why
they're doing what they're doing. It's
asking the reflective question of what
is about what they're doing that is
making my emotions feel out of place.
Too often we think about our needs, our
emotional needs in a given
communication. We think about how we're
feeling because we feel it bubbling to
the top. I feel my emotions starting to
rise up. I can tell I'm getting stressed
out. I mean maybe my eyes are starting
to water and things are starting to to
to rise and ignite within myself and I
don't know how to voice it.
Instead, when you don't voice your needs
and use the phrase I need, like I need a
moment.
I need to take a moment to digest what
you just said. I need to take a break. I
need to understand what you said. When
you put out the words I need, it makes
it to where you are voicing your
emotions out loud. Instead of you
bottling them all up, which increases
that ignition, increases that uh tension
in your body, you are saying it out
loud. Say, I need to understand what
you're saying because it's making me
feel a certain way. By putting out your
needs or saying I can tell I'm not ready
for this conversation. I can tell I'm
not feeling myself. Or as easy as
saying, I feel sad when you say that. I
feel upset or I feel defensive when you
make that kind of comment or when you
talk about this topic. Whenever you put
these kind of statements out there, it's
becoming much more emotionally
intelligent because you're recognizing
what is happening within your body.
You're not just keeping it all in. You
are voicing it to where you're able to
share exactly what you need. Like, it's
okay to assert your needs in a
conversation. To always feel instead
like you're having to be walked on, that
you have to cater to everybody else and
that people please. Absolutely not. You
are somebody that can voice their needs
at any time in the conversation. So, I
want you to feel confident and I want
you to feel firm and to be able to say,
I need you.
I need this. I need to talk about this.
When you say, I need, it makes it much
more reflective and you emotionally more
intelligent about how you're feeling in
that moment. I use the phrase, I need, a
lot in my communication when I need to
add time as a variable into the
communication. Often, people rush
things. They rush conversations when I'm
not ready, when you're not ready.
Uh or I can tell my the way I'm feeling
is starting to bubble up and my my
heart's starting to beat faster.
Whenever I feel that happening, you can
increase your emotional intelligence,
your emotional fluency, by saying, I I
need a moment. That's probably my most
often. I need some time to to think on
this, to chew on this. I just need a
pause for me to add some distance to
help my my body regulate and make sure
my analytical is not allowing my
emotional to take over. And that leads
really to the the second part is having
something to learn, not something to
prove.
And this is Let me tell you why that's
important. When you are focused solely
on proving something to somebody, that
that means you um You see this all the
time. People feel like they have to or
you have to change their mind.
That's That's trying to prove something.
I'm trying to win against you. I need
you to see things exactly the way I see
them. I need you I need you to agree
with the exact type of way that my mind
is thinking in this moment. When you're
trying to prove a certain position
against them, they often will tighten up
and believe something even more. They
They become even more convinced that
they're right, the more you push to try
and prove that they're wrong. So,
instead, you become much more
emotionally intelligent when you realize
that's happening within you.
And you kind of become,
you know, water off a duck's back is
what the phrase I grew up saying. It's
water off a duck's back. In other words,
you just let those kind of problems and
emotions beat off of you to understand
that you are much more concerned about
what to ask them. The question to ask.
And that means you have something to
learn. When I can go into a conversation
with somebody, especially when it's
heated, and I can say to myself,
"Am I trying to prove something or am I
trying to learn something right now in
this moment?"
You see how I can even tag that
together? Hey, I I I need I need a pause
for a moment.
Even 5 seconds, I can talk to myself and
say, "Am I trying to prove something or
am I trying to learn something right
now?" And too often it's me trying to
prove something. And I can flip the
whole dynamic of the conversation when I
focus on, "What's something that I can
learn about them? Something small."
Rather than me trying to force-feed them
my opinion and then getting upset that
they don't take it hook, line, and
sinker. Instead, you have something to
learn, not something to prove. And
number three, lastly, what triggers you
teaches you. Now, this is one of my
favorite phrases uh to talk about
because it is so true, as much as I
sometimes wish that it wasn't. And that
is when somebody has triggered you. In
other words, they've done something that
is raising, bringing up this negative
adverse reaction uh to you and you feel
triggered by what they've done.
Often, the first place we point the
finger is at them. They say, "I can't
believe you did that. How do you dare do
that? Why would you do that? You should
know that what you did is going to
affect me that way."
Emotionally intelligent people
point the finger at themselves first.
You know, having something to learn, not
something to prove. And they ask the
question. They get curious and say,
"What is it about what they did that is
causing this reaction within me?"
So, we all have triggers. In In we all
have a button that somebody can press.
And the people that are closest with us,
they're the ones that know these
triggers the best.
But too often, we don't ask the question
ourselves,
"Well, yes, there's a trigger, and yes,
there's a button, but why is there a
button there in the first place?"
So, why why is there a button? What is
it about this behavior that triggers me?
What is it about what they said that is
causing me to feel uh so out of place
with my emotions? And we just don't ask
that question. If you want to be much
more emotionally intelligent, you have
to know your triggers. In other words,
you have to know your buttons. And the
reason why that's important is because
you don't put yourself in positions for
somebody else to press that button.
You don't talk about things where you
invite people to press that button.
That's the hard part, is that you don't
put yourself in a position to where you
aren't going to be emotionally
intelligent. Emotionally intelligent
people prevent themselves from being in
situations where you're going to be
triggered.
That's That's the hard part of it. Once
you know your triggers, you know the
areas to avoid. And in a circular
fashion, that makes you much more
emotionally intelligent. The key to
handling conflict is not what you say.
It is what you observe.
In today's episode, I'm going to teach
you exactly what I teach every single
one of my legal clients. So, if you've
ever wondered, "What's it like to be a
legal client of Jefferson?" Well, today
is your chance to do that. Today is the
lucky day. We're going to dive into how
do you handle high-stress conflict
situations and operate at a different
level that you did not know was
possible. All right, now, let's keep
going. When we talk about difficult,
high-stress conflict, I'm I'm talking
about not just a little bitty everyday
arguments. I'm talking about something
that's on your plate that's coming up
right now, and you go, "Jefferson, I
don't know how to handle this. I I don't
know what to do. I I'm afraid I'm going
to shut down. I'm afraid I'm going to
get nervous. I'm going to tell you
exactly what I tell every single one of
my clients. You ready? Number one,
it is not what you say. It is not
anything to do with your mouth. It has
everything to do with your
nervous system.
And the key here is instead of
absorbing, [snorts]
you're observing.
I'm going to say it again. Instead of
absorbing,
you're observing. If you want to handle
conflict at a different level of
consciousness that you did not know you
could handle it,
it is going to be the key of not
absorbing what they say, but observing
what they say.
All right, say it with me. Say it with
me wherever you are. It's not absorbing,
it's observing.
All right, what does that mean?
I want you to think, this is just coming
to me right now. I want you to think
you're in the grocery store and you have
your your cart with you and you're going
through and you or maybe maybe you're
somebody who likes a bag, you know, you
you you have a I'm I'm all for
environmentally friendly stuff, too,
though it's hard here in Texas.
And you have your cart
and you just start putting things on the
shelf.
You're grabbing things off the shelf and
putting it in your basket that you you
don't even want. Right? You don't even
want. The things just start to come in.
You're like, yeah, you know what? I'm
going to take their belittling opinion
of me. I'm going to put it in my cart.
You know what? I'm going to take their
side eye, put it in my cart. I'm going
to take that that disrespectful tone,
and put that in my cart. And you just
keep going all the way through, aisle by
aisle. And then you go to checkout,
which is actually a a very good word for
this. Yeah, you you you mentally check
out. And you know what checks in? Your
nervous system, your emotions. And they
just flood you in that moment. In in in
in that point in time, you have
absorbed, you have taken on so many
things that there's nothing left for
you.
You're not observing, you're not seeing
what's happening, you're just in it.
You're just in it and you are helpless
to it. It is no longer you who controls
the emotions. The emotions are now
controlling you and there's no telling
what you're going to say. There's no
There's no
Nobody can guess what's going to come
out of your mouth or what's going to
happen because you're not there. You are
checked out. So, when I tell my clients,
"Hey, when you're in the chair and
somebody is the other attorney is asking
you questions, there's going to be a
time where all of a sudden you're
tempted to go in it.
To to to go down the spiral and look
inside and look at yourself and feel
emotions and get heated because you're
going to start taking things personally.
You're going to start absorbing what
they're saying. No, no, no, no. If you
want to handle this the right way, the
proper way in conflict, you have to
start observing. What does that mean?
That means you're going to approach the
conversation at a different level of
consciousness that you have before. That
means instead of going, "How How could
he say that to me? Oh my gosh, I'm
And you start
holding your breath and you start
getting flustered and you get nervous or
maybe you tear up. It's because you're
not seeing it as, "Huh,
I wonder why he's asking me this. I
wonder why she's saying that. I wonder
where they're going with this."
Look for the intent behind the words.
The intent behind the words. When you
are observing what's happening, in some
sense being an attached observer. I've
said this before where you It's like you
are sitting in a movie theater with your
popcorn and you're watching the
conversation take place and that puts
you in a different perspective of
looking at the person who's talking to
you.
And thinking, "I wonder why that
character is saying this. I wonder what
the plot is. I wonder what the narrative
is. I wonder what scene is coming up
next." And you see how when you look at
it that way,
you have full control. You're now the
director, the producer, the screenwriter
of exactly what happens next. And then
it's just action. And you're able to be
in the state of mind of hey, I'm
observing the conversation. And from
there, that gives you a chance to let
your body regulate because you're not in
it. You are seeing [snorts] it. You're
seeing the conversation. Number two,
what I teach every one of my clients is
something that's at the forefront of my
book, The Next Conversation, Argue Less,
Talk More. And rule number one, when I
say say it with control, and that is let
your breath
be the first word
that you say.
I've been talking a little fast here in
this podcast, which is unlike me. I
think I
I'll tell you why. I drank
too much coffee this morning. Too much
coffee, admittedly.
Usually I talk pretty slow, all right?
Can you hear how
just the way I'm talking now
and how I'm slowing down just a little
bit
might in a micro
percentage
also slow you down
a little bit.
Maybe, you know, the neural activity in
your brain is starting to slow down just
a little bit. Maybe you feel a little
bit more relaxed at me speaking a little
more slowly. When I put
breath
before my words
it is making sure that I am regulating
myself.
And even more importantly, I am showing
you
I am showing you that I am regulated,
that I'm in control.
And what I'm about to say, I've chosen.
I've chosen those words.
It makes a very big difference. So, when
I teach my clients, hey, don't get
wrapped up. Don't try and step on
somebody's question. Don't try to
interrupt them. Let them get it out. And
then you observe the question. Observe
the the interaction. Take a breath.
and then choose what you want to say.
You are in complete control of the pace
of any conversation. Nobody can make you
say anything you don't want to say, and
nobody can make you say it at a time you
don't want to say it. That choice is
yours.
That choice is yours. And I cannot tell
you how many clients
I have seen come to find, accept, and
then grow in their own power and their
own sense of value and worth of wow, I I
get to choose if I say anything. And you
know what? If I want to wait 30 seconds
before I say something, I can do that.
I It's It is a freeing feeling to know
Mhm.
You know what? I'm going to think about
this. Let me chew on this question for a
second.
Just that alone,
the ability to say that
says, "Oh, no, no, no. I'm I'm operating
at a different level you don't know
about. No, I'm I'm not who you thought I
was. I know exactly what I'm doing. I'm
going to choose my words,
and I'm going to show you that what I'm
about to say is something that I
absolutely mean, and I'm saying with
intention."
All right. You Can you feel the
difference? So, what kind of breath are
we talking about? I've run through this
breath before. It's always good to do it
because it's something that is good for
me, too. It's a conversational breath,
and what it does, it's based on a
physiological sigh, which is a double
Well, that kind of sounded weird. Double
inhalation.
Double inhalation. So, you're breathing
you're inhaling twice. All right. So,
you ready with me? We're going to
breathe through your nose. Wherever you
are, just do it. Don't worry about it.
People might look at you. Don't worry.
Ready? We're going to breathe in through
your nose about 2 to 3 seconds.
One more at the top.
>> [snorts]
>> And then let out through your nose.
My guess is you're starting to come down
a little bit. Maybe your shoulders
relaxed a little bit.
It's the feeling that mimics a sigh.
When you use that kind of breath, and I
promise you, you continue to do it while
I'm talking right now, you'll see that
you get really good at it. You can do it
anytime.
The most crucial part for me is when I
teach my clients to do it is before they
answer the question. Just take
2 seconds
or 1 second.
Always like to say here in the South is
just say one Mississippi. In other
words, in in your head you're going to
go
Mississippi.
Like well you you can use your own name
if you have a long name. You know, just
whatever it is, it's it's to get you in
the mindset of taking a beat, a moment.
Take that breath and choose what you
want to say. It is always going to be
better. And number three, the third
thing that I teach every single one of
my clients
is to use less words.
Say
less. Now, in the legal context, if my
witness
starts to give a very long answer, you
know what happens? Every Why did I say
it like that? Happens?
What happens is I guarantee them
that the opposing attorney is now going
to slice up
that long answer they just gave and turn
that into five more questions, 10 more
questions. The shorter the answer
the stronger
more
clear it is every single time. If I give
you an answer that is short and concise,
you can do nothing with it.
You can do nothing with it. Hear the
difference. So, I might have a client
who I've trained and we we practice a
lot. And when she might take a breath
and answer a question and go
No.
And that's it. That's the only answer.
What What can the other attorney do?
Nothing. They can't do anything with it.
They can only go to their next question.
But I've also had it, despite my
training
and teaching, where somebody goes,
"You know, I'm not sure. You know, that
it was just such a hectic day, and you
know, I forgot to go pick up the eggs,
and my and my dog was sick, and you
know, he just
it just, you know, peanut butter messes
up his system, and I just find it" and
you're going and I'm going, "Oh my gosh,
what is happening?" So, that happens.
That happens cuz people are are human,
right? So, we have to take a break, and
I go, "What What are we doing? Come on.
Get back So,
you see the difference in if somebody's
giving a very long answer,
some practical things happen.
One is
I'm giving the witness is giving more
information than is needed.
Right? Unnecessary information, which
means the other person, let's put this
in everyday application. Everyday people
are going to get confused as to what the
answer is. They're going to fill in
their own assumptions of why you're not
answering it directly. They're going to
hear that there's just more words, which
just
automatically leads to the possibility
of more confusion and more
miscommunication. We don't want that. We
want short, concise. So, I like to say
it when I when I teach,
is that if I ask you,
"Do you have the time?
Do you know what time it is?"
That means I'm going to ask you to stop
and ask that question in your mind, "Do
I know what time it is?" What am I
asking?
Do you know what time it is?
And if you give me the time, "Oh, it's
um 8:03."
That's the wrong answer.
That's the wrong answer. If I say, "Do
you know the time?" The answer is yes, I
do. It's that detailed. It is that
detailed because in my world,
it has to be that detailed. You have to
be. And in everyday conversation, those
high-stake, high-emotion, just when
everything is on the the table,
everything's on the line.
Every little word of clarity matters
a great deal.
And I have to make sure that you're
prepared.
So, when you condense your words into
something that is very short, very
concise,
the longer of an answer you give, the
more
opportunity there is for
miscommunication, more opportunity there
is for somebody to take your answer and
twist it. Here's an example. Have you
ever been in a text argument with
somebody? I have. And I know you have.
And it
they just sent you something and you're
like, "Oh, really?" And you just start
texting on your phone, just going after
it. And you write a paragraph. I'm
talking you just you hit them so good
and it's perfect and you're it's it's
this is exactly how I feel.
And you send it
and they send
a text that doesn't even address
anything that you said at all. Or maybe
they addressed one part that they could
defend and like, but they ignored all
the rest. It's that same principle.
You're giving someone way too much to
take and to twist. So, if you want to
handle high conflict like I teach every
one of my clients, you have to keep your
answers as short as possible. Answer
their question and only their question.
All right?
Okay. Hey, look, you're you're ready.
You're ready. I know we we maybe we're
going to need to talk about this. Let's
go grab some coffee. Make sure you get
some snacks. Feel good. We're about to
go into this deposition room together
and you're going to do awesome. I
promise. What did we talk about today?
When it comes to high-stakes
conversation, number one,
observe, don't absorb.
Observe, don't absorb. Number two, use
your breath
>> [gasps]
>> as the first word that you say. Slow it
down and choose your words. Be
intentional with them. Make sure that
you are operating on your time frame,
not somebody else's. And number three,
say less. Shorten your answers. When you
give way too much, you allow the
opportunity for somebody to grab onto
it, pieces, and say things you didn't
mean. You're giving them more to twist.
You're giving them more to twist. It's
like
giving somebody a long piece of rope.
They They're able to put a bunch of
knots in it. But if you just give them a
little bit of rope, it may be it's not
even enough to do a
the tie their shoe with, right?
It's a big difference. You want to make
sure that you're very short and concise.
Man, my um
examples today are all over the place.
We talked about the grocery store. We
talked about shoelaces. Man, what a
what a day. What an episode.
>> And you really dive into nervous system
regulation and explaining that. And it's
something frankly we've had guests on to
talk about that. We've done a lot of
firmament of study ourselves on that.
But I never considered it in the context
of communication.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is kind of odd because
it's like probably the most important
thing, which I'm I
I guess that's why you started with it
first. But can you unravel that?
>> The whole point of why rule number one
in the book is say with control is
because if you
do not have control, well then none of
the rest matters. Doesn't matter how
uh quick of a statement I could give
you, a twist of the word, a way to
reframe, it doesn't matter a lick if you
do not have control.
And what people are so quick to forget
is that you are in complete control
of the pace of the conversation. And I
say that because I train, I prepare
hundreds of clients for their
deposition.
And they get into this mentality of
well, if this person's asking me a
question, this attorney's asking me a
question, I need to have a rapid-fire
response, or I I need to be on the
ready. Or anything.
And I have to continually remind them
and say, "No, no, no, no. Listen, you
are in control of the conversation. They
can't ask a question faster than you can
respond to it.
There is nothing that they can do
nothing they can do to make you respond
faster. Do you understand that? There's
nothing anybody can do to force you to
say something, force you to speak. It is
all within your time frame and
timetable.
And the sooner that people understand
that
almost innately, the more in control
they feel of themselves, of you can ask
me a question
and I can choose to not answer it at
all. I can choose to answer it in 5
seconds. I can choose
anything that I want, but it's that
pause that you can throw in there that
truly is a
a game-changer in all of your
communication. Do you have to say it
with
control.
>> What is the value of that? If you go at
the other person's pace and sort of the
natural trajectory of an argument
what's at stake there versus doing it
the way you're talking about, putting a
pause in?
>> When you don't put in a pause and you I
don't add your breath, when when you
don't say it with control, you end up
reacting rather than responding. It's
it's just your your natural fight or
flight will take over and you're going
to start responding more emotionally.
So, the attorneys will do this thing
where
we will start to ask questions faster
and you'll start to respond faster. That
means you're thinking about your
your answer less,
which means I'm probably getting the
answer I want. And so, whenever I can
get you in this rhythm
the yes, no, okay, I don't know, like
it's faster I can get you in that
rhythm,
the more it the more I got you. The more
I know
I can lead you where I want to lead you.
The witness I need to cross-examine. If
I ask them a question and they
immediately go, yes. Yeah, no, that's
yeah, I think that's true. Yes.
That quickness, like, okay, they're not
listening.
But, the the witness who goes
Yeah, I think I think so. I think so.
That right there, I'm like, oh, dang.
Okay, this is somebody who I can't do
anything with. It doesn't matter what I
say,
they're going to actually listen
to what I'm asking them and it's a it's
a much different It's the same thing
when I'm the one questioning the other
attorney or
I'm seeing another attorney. If there's
another attorney who's asking questions
and he's rapid fire, sometimes he's not
really thinking of what hearing what the
witness is saying cuz he's looking down
at his next question, right? Same thing
with like people who interview, they're
not really listening to the person.
They're looking at They're worried of
like, what's going to be my next
question?
>> Yep.
>> Attorneys do that, too. And I know it's
a good attorney if they have their notes
and they just push them off to the side
and they're just looking at my witness.
And you know, they're taking their time
before question. I'm like, dang. Okay,
they they're they're really they're
locked in. Yeah, they're they're
somebody that you already know, okay,
you you uh you better be on your game.
>> Well, it seems like in a personal
relationship, too, it just really keeps
it from escalating cuz once you get into
that fight or flight thing, it spirals
out of control.
>> I had this actually happen recently. I
was in a conversation in a professional
conversation and it started to escalate
and it was kind of one of those things
where it's like you're you're sort of
having an out-of-body experience in your
head, like, what's happening right now?
Like, what I said this, [clears throat]
but why is the other person responding
like that? And
I was on the the more regulated end, but
I was feeling myself kind of escalate
and I thought to to myself in my own
head, okay, wait a second.
We are now in a place of fight or flight
in this conversation. Like, the other
person is not even hearing what I'm
saying, is not able to respond, like
something else has gotten triggered
here. And I realized I need to sort of
be,
you know, like in nervous system
language, like I need to be the
co-regulator of I need to slow my voice
down. I need to make sure I'm breathing
and relaxing my body, and I need to talk
in ways that are very intentionally
non-threatening because we're not even
talking about what we're talking about
anymore, you know? But it was like just
such an interesting moment of like
the kindest thing that I can do in this
situation, because it really wasn't an
argument between us, it was just it was
about something else, was to take
control of the situation by getting
myself regulated so I could let them
sort of borrow that regulation that they
couldn't access in that moment, you
know? And that was that was kind of a
profound realization of it's not it's
not just being in control for my own
sake, for to be more persuasive or to
just my kind of maintain my equilibrium,
but sometimes, you know, people can get
triggered in conversations for reasons
that really don't have anything to do
with you.
And they need help, you know?
>> You know? Yeah, and I
even to your point, I mean the the
mutual benefit,
the double benefit of
the pause before you say anything, what
I teach is let your breath be the first
word that you say. You know, when you do
take the pause,
the the other benefit is not only does
it calm yourself down, it calms the
other person down. So, sometimes I might
pause before I say something, not so
much to even control what I say, it's to
make the other person
slow down. Because when you can tell
they're getting triggered, they're
getting worked up, they're starting to
raise their voice.
And when you add in that space,
they understand and they hear that
they're going to have to come down to
match match my energy. And that's that's
going to always equal a much better
conversation.
>> By the way, this works with toddlers,
too.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> If you have young kids, you're doing
this all the time or either positively
or negatively, but you know, I've had
this moment so many times with my own
kids where you just you have to be the
one to regulate the conversation down
cuz my gosh, if you follow them, you're
going to be on the floor kicking and
screaming like they are before you know
it.
>> [laughter]
>> With regard to control, you kind of have
that three-part framework, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Starts with the breath.
One of the things that I find is
difficult is I can be swept up
into an argument and very self-unaware
of what's happening.
But you've got a way to prevent against
that
that you talk about in small talk. So,
could you unpack that?
>> Yeah, there these little things I call
small talks. There's nothing fancy to
it. It's simply a talk that you have
with your yourself. If there's one
person you should know better than
anyone, it should be
yourself. That's a statement in of
itself. You know, you're doing doing
that on in a work.
But small talks are
these phrases that begin with a verb
that help ground you in conversation.
And
and it started with
I was in trial, I would write things at
the top of my notepad that would ground
me.
And these are little things like
you be Jefferson or let the facts speak
for themselves.
Uh little things that would help center
me in conversation. Now, I'm not saying
every person in every conversation is
like, well, I I need to
have this granola woo-woo moment where
I, you know, have this this this uh
enlightenment before I have this
conversation. No, it's just it's
something short and simple.
And you want to begin with a a verb.
Maybe it's as simple as be assertive or
stand up straight or stand firm or be
still. Little things that you can say to
yourself when you feel that you're
you're coming undone.
Everybody has these arguments where all
of a sudden you feel unsteady. I feel I
feel like I'm spiraling. I feel like I'm
coming unraveled. These moments where
it's it's not great.
And these small talks are just something
that help guide you. One of my favorites
is a a client that I had. She
she's so sweet. And she was always
very timid, but her grandmother was not.
Her grandmother's name was Doris.
And she'd [snorts] get all sassy. She'd
say she get she she had no problem
telling somebody what she thought.
And whenever she would get on a tear,
her husband, my client's grandfather,
would say, "You tell them, Doris."
"You tell them, Doris." That would be
the their line.
You know, he's got I'm sure he's got I
can already see it like he's got his
paper, not even looking up at her, and
she's going on about something. He'd
say, "You you tell it, Doris." There you
go.
That [laughter] was that was her That
was her small talk.
Uh and so whenever she felt like, "No,
no, you know what? I do need to say
something. I do need to you know, I'm
not going to just say yes or okay
when that's just not the truth." And so
that was her small talk. "You tell them,
Doris." And I loved it.
>> That's hilarious. What a great story.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, I think it I think it goes to the
fact that we need to be more thoughtful
in these conversations, particularly the
ones that are high stake and there's a
lot of stress around it or we have a lot
of history, you know, of conflict within
that relationship. But I can think of
one relationship that I have
where unfortunately it devolves into
political conflict. So much so that I
said at one point, "I'm I'm we're we're
just never going to talk about politics
again because
it's just too nerve-racking." Yeah.
And I I think there's a way to have that
conversation. And and in fact, we have
had a couple of subsequent conversations
where
it's been easier cuz I think that both
of us have been more mindful of that.
>> Yeah, being thoughtful is a such an
important just concept for any
conversation, especially the the
difficult ones. Political arguments,
political conversations tend to be so
because we tie them to the collective.
We we believe that there is a good side
and a bad side. And neither side is We
don't say there's a good side and a good
side. One is bad, one is good, and the
bad side is never ours.
And we want to tie them to a bigger
picture
of no, this is the one that's winning.
And the other says, "No, this is the
side that's winning."
Who Is there ever a finish line? Is
there ever a win? No. And not It's
always going to continue to go on, but I
think some of it too is people
desperately want to feel important, and
they want to feel right. And you add
that with people who mostly talk
politics, like my grandfather
uh and his brother
could not be any polar opposite on the
political spectrum.
And they do this thing where they'll get
in a a shouting match over politics that
will never touch their life. Understand
Nothing that's happening in politics is
ever going to touch them. It's not going
to change a bit about their world. It
doesn't matter at all.
They're just home all day
thinking of things to gripe about, and
they will get [laughter] to arguing with
each other.
And then they hang up. They hang up on
each other. They get They get so mad,
they hang up. And by the afternoon
they call again.
And then they're just as happy as can
be, and they don't talk politics at all.
And so, but I think some of it too of
especially older generations, they just
want to feel like something matters, and
they want to feel like they they can get
up in arms about something. I see this a
lot. Like older attorneys
they may not have that many clients.
When I have them in hearings, oh they
can just be mean.
And it's because
you have to just kind of let them go
because they're trying to feel alive in
that moment. They're trying to feel like
something they say is matters and have
an opinion.
And by God, I'm going to share that
opinion. It's the only opinion that
matters. And they can't really back it
up, but who cares?
And so, I I think that is exactly right.
Being thoughtful in conversations is
um incredibly important and knowing that
when you can
>> [snorts]
>> control yourself is the first step
because you can't control anything else
about what
they are doing. You can't control uh a
thing of it. You can only You can only
control yourself trying to bring them to
match your energy.
>> One of the things I have learned after
raising five daughters and my wife, so
six very important women in my
>> raise her, though.
>> I didn't raise her. She raised me, to be
truthfully told.
But, at any rate, one of the things I've
noticed, and they maybe notice this
about me, too, is that when they're
upset,
if I will just hold space to hear them
out,
it will burn out.
>> I love that when people say hold space
or in the mean just be quiet.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, shut up.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. I Which is true. I
mean, it's it's I I love the visual of
Now, I'm just holding the space for you.
I'm I'm I am I'm here. I'm present.
You You're This is a safe place. We got
this. In practice, it just means I'm not
saying a word. It means I am going to
listen without trying to solve it,
without trying to say, "Well, what you
need to do is"
Like any of that, you can just throw
that out the window. When you can simply
listen,
easier said than done. What I tried to
teach my kids,
whenever somebody is upset about
something, you have to let them get it
all out. It's this visual of
There's no way I could pour new thoughts
a glass that's already full.
You got to let it let them pour it all
out before they'll ever be willing to
accept anything that you say. And that's
particularly true with changing anyone's
mind. You can't You're not going to
change somebody's mind in two sentences
and say, "How how how what an idiot. How
could you possibly think that?" That's
never going to get them to
change their mind. They're never going
to say, "Oh, you're so right. I am such
an idiot. What what did you say? Oh,
yes, that's correct." Like nobody's
going to ever say that. And and nobody
can do it over one conversation. It's
typically it it might take
conversation after conversation over 6
months or a year before you can change
somebody's mind.
If you enjoyed that clip and want to see
the rest of the conversation, you can
click right here. Or if you want to see
the latest episode of the Jefferson
Fisher podcast, click right here and
I'll meet you there.